[Music]
[Applause]
he is our good buddy Ross Tucker host of
the Ross Tucker football podcast and he
can be found on social media at Ros
Tucker NL uh we call him the uh Mead
James vanderbeek the uh great actor he
looks a lot like Ross Tucker who joins
us on the program ladies and gentlemen
Ross
Tucker
yeah how are you boys boys first Jame
James vanderbeek was uh on what was that
Saved by the Bell is that uh Dawson
Creek OH Dawson's Creek Dan true story
okay okay nobody ever told me that I
look like James vanderbeek until a
couple times when I filled in for you
and then it became this thing Meathead
James vanderbeek one of my roles for
Westwood one is at the end of the
conference Championship game I interview
the winning head coach and quarterback
when they come down off the podium okay
so I talked to Mahomes for a minute and
I'm talking to Andy Reid and he's got
his arm around his wife Tammy Reid and
she's just smiling listening as I'm
doing the interview the interview ends
and she looks at me and she says has
anyone ever told you you look like the
guy from Dawson's
Creek I was like Paulie told you to say
that didn't he like there's no way like
Andy re wife said out of the blue maybe
she listens or watches the show I don't
know Mead James vanderby yeah I like it
I like me I mean he's not a badl looking
guy no I mean I don't I don't know that
he's my level but he's not a badl
looking guy and he couldn't get into
Princeton like you did well I'm still
mad about um Varsity
Blues the movie he was in yeah well
number one if you have an
opportunity for the whipped cream Sunday
or whatever that was you and you're in
high school and you're playing football
you take advantage of that opportunity
so I'm a little upset that he didn't
take advantage of the whipped cream what
what they call Whi cream
aler wh secondly he was so focused on
getting into Brown when they're trying
to win a West Texas state championship
yeah I mean get some priorities
vanderbeek yeah I mean his dad had the
right priorities okay his dad knew that
they had to play State high on Wednesday
whatever it was amazing okay best
football movies ooh that's a good
question
um I'm kind of a softy for like a
Rudy yeah I'm kind of a softy for like a
Rudy Sean loves it well no see that's a
documentary Satan says it's not a movie
that's a
documentary love documentaries but so um
I grew up going to some third Dame games
but also okay but when Montana came on
our show a few years ago and basically
dispelled any of the myth of uh of Rudy
uh that hurts caught a lot of heat too
there were a lot of people upset with
Joe Montana like don't you dare tell me
that Rudy didn't really get that sack he
was off sides first of all right that's
my favorite for any not Dame game where
like college game day some of you'll
have the sign Rudy was off sides it's so
good but it is true it's so good he did
jump the the it's so funny Dan I
actually sent back in the mid90s okay I
sent out 35 VH CH tapes to colleges my
coach I was onea but I sent to nerame in
pen anyway right and I got a letter back
from ner about if I wanted to walk on
and so I can sort of uh I can sort of
think about what that was like for for
Rudy which by the way kills me because
growing up in Pennsylvania I had Penn
say season tickets and my wife hates
when I say this but once I made the NFL
the Penn State guys like LaVar Arrington
and Kenny Watson they were like man you
were started like 3 years for us and I
was like oh don't tell me that don't
tell me that don't tell me that and my
wife wanted to go to Princeton so she's
always like if you say that one more
time different perspectives he's a mead
James vanderbeek Ross Tucker Westwood
One CBS Sports NFL and college football
analyst it was on this day in 2012 when
the Giants beat the Patriots to win the
Super Bowl was that the one where I got
roasted going on Letterman and I said
the Giants will win the Super Bowl and
he said have you been drinking and and I
hadn't but I remember you taped the show
in the like at 5 5:30 yeah I got done
and I think Paulie said you know like
what did you do and I said I said the
Giants will beat the Patriots he goes
That's crazy and I so nothing happens so
it's done at 5:30 6:00 I drive home show
airs that night the next day people are
going how stupid are you that you think
the Giants will beat the pat Patriots
and I said I thought that because they
had played the Patriots the final
regular season game I think that year
and so I thought okay they're not afraid
of them they know what to expect now was
I surprised that they won I was but I
just remember making a prediction where
it just kind of lingers it hangs out
there and you go I'm going to get
crucified have you had one of those
predictions where you go why did I say
that well so what's Wild is I had six
different people text message me this
morning
cuz I went on some radio station in
Kansas City and I Saidi have no idea why
the 49ers are favored in this game it
just doesn't make any sense to me I mean
you watch the three Chiefs playoff games
Dan they were the better team in all
three including at Buffalo at Baltimore
meanwhile the ners I mean I can think of
six plays maybe off the top of my head
against the Packers where if that went
the other way Kea Nixon dropped the pick
Darnell Savage dropped a pick the
Packers would have won and then and the
lions were bashing the Niners brains in
until they had that might have been one
of the most
painful collapses meltdowns that I've
ever seen and I'm not even I'm not like
a lions fan but that was hard to watch
so anyway I just said it doesn't seem
logical to me that the 49ers would be
favorite now they might win but I guess
my point would be if these teams played
10 times I think the Chiefs win seven
maybe eight so I have no idea why that
got news but it it got picked up by a
certain um cable news Outlet so my
friends or people I know in my life are
telling my dad they're telling on
themselves for what cable news outlet
they watch because they're all texting
me you're on the front page of bleep
bleep bleep I mean it was I was like
really for just saying I'm surprised the
Niners are favored is that I don't feel
like that that's like aren't you a
little surprised the ners are favored
yeah yeah but I don't want to say
anything more cuz I don't want to end up
on the front page or somebody like you
know it's weird how when you make a
prediction they think you either love
their team or you hate their team right
so when I say like I'd never bet against
Patrick Mahomes I I just wouldn't I I
wouldn't bet against Tom Brady I mean
I've learned I've been doing this 40
years I I I sort of have this figured
out here and so when they when I say I'd
never roote against Patrick bomes oh so
you don't like the Niners or you don't
like Brock pry I go no no it's not that
I don't I don't have any bias whatsoever
if you said the Niners are going to be
you know Dominate and it's going to be
an RVE performance in Brock py MVP I go
awesome I'm just analyzing a stock
that's all this is I'm looking at a
stock and the stock is Patrick Mahomes
I'm investing in that and you know
they're two point underdogs and I
wouldn't be surprised you know that if
they go off as a betting favorite if
people you know start to look at the
numbers here and Dan you referenced Tom
Brady and I think that's the right name
for Patrick Mahomes and the reason why I
say that is I don't know if it's
conscious or subconscious but we're to
the point now where you know the Chiefs
they went to Baltimore I thought
Baltimore was the best team in the
league this year right the Chiefs went
in there they took it right to them and
I remember like I play with Drew bledo I
started a bunch of games in Buffalo Dre
blood Soo really good quarterback and we
thought we were going to win because we
had blood Soo when I went to New
England you know you're going to win you
have the guy like even if you're down
two scores late you're literally
thinking your head we're still going to
win we have Brader we have momes it's
just a matter of how and I think that
that subconsciously seeps in because
then the other teams start doing stupid
stuff the Ravens are getting penalties
the Ravens you know Lamar Jackson had
one of the worst playoff interception
I've ever seen and it just seems like
people make critical errors dumb
mistakes against the Patriots against
the Chiefs where you're like what are
they doing and I don't know if it's
conscious or subconscious but it's a
fact yeah because if anything you have
to keep your composure like you can't
try to force things but that's what they
they they sort of speed you up a little
bit um speaking of the Patriots I said
last week I don't see Bill bellich
coaching in the NFL again as a head
coach ever again I just unless it's
Dallas unless something happens and then
Jerry Jones goes all right come on in
bill I got to win one while I'm still
alive maybe the
Eagles but you would know better since
you cover the Eagles if that owner
Jeffrey Lorry I mean I think they were
interested in him they just didn't pull
the trigger if you're bringing I mean
Nick serani is he's on it's a really
it's as hot as that you know that flame
behind you there under his seat I just
don't know if somebody's going to go to
Bill come on in and run the show here I
don't know if they're going to do that I
would be shocked if he's not hired as a
head coach a year from now two reasons
number one I I don't know what the right
term for this is Dan but I think he's
going to have like a media cleansing
this year he's going to work somewhere
in the media he's going to be insightful
he's going to show personality and
there's something weird about when you
stop coaching and people see a different
side of you because they're only used to
the um just on the Cincinnati like
they're only that wait was that Bill
Murray and I don't know I don't know
that was a terrible story
[Laughter]
flowing robes beautiful uh so uh no I
think I think after a year in the media
a year from now a lot of people are
gonna be like you know what I like him
he is the best coach ever they're going
to forget what a jerky is in press
conference now and I don't know if it's
like media cleansing or whatever that
and the fact Dan I know you know him
decently well no I don't well well I
think you know this part he he wants
that record bad I don't care I don't
care what he says he wants that record
bad so if a year from now he has to
Humble himself and just be a head coach
I think he overplayed his hand this year
yeah I think he thought he could run the
whole show in Atlanta that's what he
went for next year now that he's out for
the whole year I think he'll put feelers
out about running the whole show but if
it comes down to it I think he'll accept
just being a coach somewhere so we can
get what is 13 wins I don't know 15 wins
so he can get that over the next couple
years and have that because you ever
know you ever notice they don't do
anything with the media but anytime the
Patriots win the Super Bowl it's like oh
my gosh NFL films has been there all
year we had no idea and they have this
documentary with the coaches like and
that's why on Third and eight we saw one
his left pinky toe was pointed outwards
he was going to run an in-breaking route
it's like wait a minute what I want to
see the videos Dan from all the years
when the Patriots stink I want to see
the NFL films cameras and guys from the
years when they're not CU they're always
there when they win the whole thing yeah
I understand what you're saying about
the media cleansing but you still have
to turn your team over to him or believe
that he is he's just going to coach and
he's not going to be part of the front
office there right I think that's that's
where you say hey no no I just want to
coach and then all of a sudden you start
coaching and then you're like Bill
showing up at meetings where you go well
what are you what are you what are you
doing here no no just coach just thought
I'd stop well that's the problem with
like Atlanta so Terry fno is the GM
there Rich McKay is the president there
you think they want to Bell no
absolutely not and they talk to Arthur
Blank every day yeah I I I don't see
that happening do you think that Brady
stays in the booth for 10 years at Fox
no I don't that would surprise me I
think he might move on to other things
I'm fascinated to see how he does um you
know nobody will be more prep
preped and he does have a good
personality I guess I'm just curious
we've never really seen him with his
guard down and we also haven't really
seen him be overly critical of people
he's a very positive person he's like
I'm going to be curious because what I
sense from him is he would be really
frustrated by dumb plays by other
quarterbacks well we see that with
Payton on the Manning cast and I'm I'm
hoping Tom is real
I'm hoping like when a quarterback does
something dumb like the Lamar Jackson
interception I hope Tom is just like
this is unaccept like because he would
get he he has a lot of anger in him
right like that's what fuels him I would
love if he's like this is unacceptable
you cannot do this I have no like that
would be good TV that would be good if
he really acted the way he normally
would when watching a quarterback do
something like that well we have Tony
Romo joining us now and uh
I don't know Jim what do you what do you
think wa that's all that's his Tony Romo
impersonation at least at least Satan
waits for you to queue him up yes he
does fritzy just goes into it thinks
it's the Todd frit show Tod just blows
through the stop sign but you know when
Jim Nano coming up following the
football game 60 Minutes except on the
west coast and then the new equalizer
third and eight Tony what do you think
will happen here
I I don't know I mean they could run it
they could pay what would you do
Jim he only said that once in a game I I
know but that didn't stop us from using
it all the time like he's asking the
play-by-play guy what would you do Jim
yeah what would you do like dude that's
why you're here Tony I think Jim Nance
is joining us uh this week is that right
Todd on Wednesday okay will we do the
Tony Romo impersonation to Jim Nance
okay I don't think Jim is going to he
won't laugh he can't laugh he can't yeah
he can't but but like deep down he might
laugh goodbye friends yes all right uh
hey great to see you always great to see
you this is unbelievable by the way yes
it is this is wonderful the fans here
it's amazing amazing they only came to
see you there they're leaving right
after this yeah um thank you for all the
contributions with the show we
appreciate it all year long no man thank
you I appreciate the opportunity it's
awesome he's Ross Tucker from Westwood
One CBS Sports take a break we'll close
up shopping after this